Let us look at the solution to our full predication quiz. We have this branch
based if, then, else code. We're trying to if convert it using full predication.
P1 here is set when R2 is zero. When R2 is zero, we branch to the else part.
So this is what gets done if R2 is zero. That means that.
We do this when P1 is true. And then of course we do this when it's not true.
The next part that we want to do is when should we do the if conversions. So
what needs to be the accuracy here. Let's foresee how many instructions we
have in each of these. Here we have three instructions with a CPI of 0.5.
This always takes us 1.5 cycles, assuming that there are other things that
can be done in the rest of the cycle. Here, when this branch is taken,
we do two instructions. When this branch is not taken, we do three instructions.
So let's split the difference and say that on average we do 2.5 instructions.
At the CPI of 0.5. That means that without a misprediction, we get 1.25 cycles.
A misprediction adds ten cycles. These two perform equally
when the cost of mispredictions here. Is 0.25 cycles per branch.
So pretty much, the difference between between these two is 0.25 cycles. So
on average, we can lose this much to get this to be equal. The penalty for
a single misprediction is 10 cycles. If we can lose only 0.25 cycles per branch.
That means that only one in 40 branches can be mis-predicted. one in 40 is 2.5%.
That means that our correct prediction needs to
be at least 97.5% to not do this conversion. If the correct
prediction rate is less that this then we a better off with if conversion.